ja und zwar mit dem bundeskanzler ich
habe heute mit großem interesse mir die
regierungserklärung von olaf scholz
angeguckt und hat vor allem darauf
geachtet was wird er wohl zu dem thema
sagen dass jeden beschäftigt nämlich
unsere gespaltene gesellschaft
und siehe da schon da hat der mann
versagt gleich am anfang versagt denn
olaf scholz hat festgestellt unsere
gesellschaft ist nicht gespalten und da
möchte man ihm zurufen herr scholz wo
leben sie eigentlich in welcher blase
befinden sie sich offenbar in einer
blase in der nur sie selbst leben in
einer art scholz blase denn deutschland
ist so zerstritten so zerrüttet zu
gestalten wie noch nie zuvor jedenfalls
noch nie seit ich mich für politische
zusammenhänge interessieren und die
spaltung geht in alle bereiche unseres
zusammenlebens eltern streiten sich
darüber ob die kinder geimpft werden
sollen oder nicht lehrer streiten
darüber wie das mit der masken pflicht
ist menschen geraten in bussen
aneinander und werden handgreiflich
kolleginnen und kollegen tuscheln und
sagen guck mal dass der kollege von
neben büro das ist doch bestimmt nicht
geimpft und war eigentlich schon bei
seinem test in bester blog wand man hier
überall wo man hinschaut ist in
deutschland spaltung nur uns olaf stellt
fest es gibt keine spaltung in unserer
gesellschaft und das ist mehr als nur
ein schlimmer von tat zum anfang meiner
regierungszeit das ist riskant es wirkt
arrogant und es ist in jedem fall
ignorant und deshalb glaube ich müsste
olaf scholz sich zu herzen nehmen nur
wer probleme wirklich benennt kann sie
auch lösen und der einfache trick da
draußen ist ein riesenproblem und ich
sage da ist gar keine sind hat man
weniger arbeit das lassen wir nicht
durchgehen das grenzte an
arbeitsverweigerung und 1 vielleicht
noch lieber olaf scholz wer probleme zu
lange weg geredet wird selber zu 1
das waren spannende suntory frau wagner
sind sie das ja ich kann ja eigentlich
nur zustimmen also ich glaube wirklich
dass es ein problem ist dass sich viele
politiker nur noch in ihrer blase
bewegen mit überwiegend gleichgesinnten
zu tun haben und dann haben sie den
eindruck ja es gibt eigentlich kein
widerspruch es gibt vielleicht ein paar
extremisten im land so ein paar
einmal üble die da auch dann wirklich
auf sehr unerfreulicher weise auf sich
aufmerksam machen auf der straße zum
beispiel aber das sei sozusagen eine
ganz verschwindende minderheit und
ehrlich gesagt was ich erlebe und auch
als ich rücke spiegelt bekommen wir so
ein mails ist etwas ganz anderes ich
meine wir schreiben leute dass ihre
kinder in der schule als mörder
beschimpft werden weil sie nicht geimpft
werden von ihr als weil die eltern nicht
möchten dass sie geimpft werden oder
dass leute richtig auch bei kollegen auf
möglich ganz üble weise angegangen
werden und es gibt ja sehr
unterschiedliche gründe warum sich
menschen nicht impfen lassen also klar
es gibt umgekehrt dann auch menschen die
sagen dass eine giftspritze die mich
umbringt die natürlich auch sich dann in
eine wirklich ganz verhärtete positionen
hereingegeben aber es gibt natürlich
menschen die haben einfach aus
gesundheitlichen gründen tatsächlich
anlass skeptisch zu sein oder sie haben
mit ihrer unmittelbaren umgebung
menschen die schwere nebenwirkungen hat
nach einer impfung da ist man natürlich
zurückhaltend und die werden dann
gemobbt die werden dann wirklich
ausgegrenzt sie werden bei familien
geburtstag nicht mehr eingeladen und man
muss natürlich auch dazu sagen die
politik befördert das also ich habe
gerade gelesen zum beispiel der
hamburger oberbürgermeister sagt jetzt
also machen sie haben sie keine kontakte
mit ungeimpften weil das sind die villen
arabien und ich meine am anfang der
pandemie wussten wir noch die variablen
das sind vor allem die älteren das sind
vor allem menschen mit bestimmten
vorerkrankungen die muss man auch
schützen da sollte man auch für
impfungen werben überhaupt keine frage
aber die art wie auch von politikern
diese spaltung befördert wird in dem man
vom eigenen versagen ablenken und so tut
als sei jetzt eine kleine gruppe in der
gesellschaft schuld daran dass wir noch
probleme haben obwohl andere länder mit
sehr hohen impfquoten auch probleme
haben das ist einfach unverantwortlich
das ist für mich wenn ich das nur sagen
dass das traurige heute an der
regierungserklärung von scholz er hätte
er die möglichkeit gehabt sozusagen um
armand und verbindend zu wirken das hat
er auch schon mal versucht hat ja auch
gesagt ich bin auch der kanzler der
ungeimpften das ist aber nicht
glaubwürdig wenn man dann sagt es gibt
gar keine spaltung also ich hätte mir
heute gewünscht dass er sagt ich sehe
die probleme ich sehe die spaltung ich
bin auch bei den menschen die sich mit
der politik unzufrieden fühlen die
sorgen haben die ängste haben die auf
die straße gehen und für ihre belange
demonstrieren und ich setze sie nicht
gleich mit den schlimmen verbrechern die
dann irgendwie nah am terrorismus
agieren ich setze sie nicht gleich ich
nehme sie als bürger war ich respektiere
sie als bürger das ist nämlich etwas was
mich am meisten zur zeit beklemmt das
würde sozusagen eine eine indirekte
aushöhlung des demonstrationsrechts
sehen das trägt auch zur spaltung bei
ich mach mir den selbst check wenn ich
jetzt meine position lautet lasst euch
bitte impfen impfen impfen aber für eine
pflicht bin ich nicht das ist sozusagen
meine position wenn ich mit der eine
demo anmelden wollen würde wäre das
risiko mir fast so groß dass irgendwie
drei verrückte radikale mir ins bild
springen und ich geld dann als chef der
querdenker die selber irgendwie
rechtsradikal oder sonst was sind das
finde ich wirklich beklemmend und der
bundeskanzler muss jetzt als versöhner
als einer als verständnisvoller
auftreten und nicht als einerseits das
problem gibt es gar nicht das fand ich
wirklich hat also
vergeigten statt also ich glaube das
widerspricht eigentlich alles was wir in
den letzten jahren auch von
sicherheitsapparate immer wieder gehört
haben ich meine diese radikalisierung
der sprache immer der erste schritt
richtung weiteren radikalisierung und
das ist nie eine einseitige horn immer
zwei seiten dazu das sind die impfgegner
die teilweise auch aggressiv auftreten
da will ich sie auch nicht alle
vorgänger gruppe sehen aber es sind auch
die andere seite die fisch moralisch
füllte sie geimpft ist und die andere
seite komplett diskriminiert und die
sprache die polarisierung die bewegung
nur in blasen hat unsere gesellschaft
und vor allem unsere demokratischen
großartiger schaden
erreicht und ich glaube es ist an die
zeit nicht nur an die politik zu
appellieren sondern es ist eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe ist auch
die aufgabe von medien ist die aufgabe
von schule als es die aufgabe von lehrer
von allen einfach so eine ganz andere
art von sprache beizutragen um das zu
mildern was wir gerade haben ist eher
richtung gewalt und das macht mir angst
er ist eine mangelnde differenzierung
das haben wir ja nicht nur in diesem
feld das haben wir eigentlich in allen
feldern das macht ja wenn man mal
ehrlich sind auch so ein bisschen spaß
wenn man sich zu einer gruppe zugehörig
fühlen kann ja mal so richtig einen
raushauen kann das ist ja auch lustig
aber man muss natürlich aufpassen und
dann im bundeskanzleramt muss ich auch
was anderes erwarten da muss ich diese
differenzierung erwarten ganz einfach
weil ich möchte dass das auch in der
gesellschaft ankommt dass man
differenzierter genauer hingucken muss
und das sieht man an diesem beispiel
überdeutlich und das macht auch mir
tatsächlich angst wenn wir in diese
richtung weitergehen das dann
tatsächlich solche dinge passieren was
eigentlich ihr ein eigenes gebiet ist
nämlich zu schauen wo bildet sich
extremismus wagenknecht wie kann jetzt
eigentlich olaf scholz wieder das
vertrauen herstellen weil ich muss
selber sagen er hat gesagt die
impfpflicht kommt nicht vor der
bundestagswahl
jetzt ist er dafür hat unerschöpflich da
eigentlich schon als neuer bundeskanzler
großen fehler gemacht was zu versprechen
und das dann in dieser dimension nicht
zu halten das war für mich persönlich
muss ich sagen als bürgerin einer der
größten wortbrüche die hier erlebt habe
ja also ich meine das trägt ja insgesamt
nicht zum vertrauen in die politik bei
dass man immer wieder erlebt übrigens
auch vielen bereichen also nicht nur bei
der im schlecht dass politiker vor der
wahl dass eine versprechen und nach der
wahl das gegenteil tun bei der
impfpflicht war es besonders krass also
da haben ja sehr viele politiker nicht
nur olaf scholz alle vorhergesagt
niemand hat die absicht eine impfpflicht
ein und jeder
wie in frage stellte der wurde dann als
verschwörungstheorie abgetan so und
danach kippte das alles ins gegenteil
und das ist nicht vertrauensbildend und
ich hatte ehrlich gesagt also ich bin
jetzt ja wirklich nicht im verdacht
irgendein anhänger der fdp zu sein aber
ich hatte doch das gefühl jetzt diese
ampel
also wirklich die wählerin gewesen aber
diese achse wäre zumindest eingeschränkt
wird
das wahlgeheimnis existiert aber die fdp
habe ich mein leben nie gewählt dass ich
viel mehr kann ich ehrlicherweise sagen
nein aber ich hatte schon das gefühl das
wird ein bisschen ein anderes herangehen
und gut jetzt gibt es einen experten war
da ist dann zumindest auch hendrik
strikt drin dann dachte ich okay ist ja
auch ein gutes zeichen aber abgesehen
von dieser einen entscheidung merke ich
nicht dass man sich wirklich auch der
eigenen verantwortung bewusst ist eine
regierung muss ein land zusammenführen
und wir sind schon vor der pandemie im
grunde ziemlich gespalten also es gibt
ja auch andere themen das fing in der
flüchtlingsfrage an wo also auch
bestimmte meinungen sofort in die ecke
rechts rassistisch den abgedrängt wurden
das ging in der klimafrage weiter wer
noch irgendwie sein diesel auto liebt
der ist also der schlimmste umweltsünder
den man sich vorstellen kann obwohl man
auf dem lande vielfach wird nicht anders
unterwegs ist so und bei corona wurde es
natürlich ganz ganz akut weil da ist ja
angst im spiel also eine extreme angst
bei vielen menschen im spiel und zwar
auf beiden seiten die einen natürlich
dass sie denken weil es noch ungeimpfte
gibt sind sie noch mit der pandemie
konfrontiert was nicht stimmt also
selbst wenn wir alle geimpft hätten wäre
es immer noch so dass die pandemie da
wäre weil jetzt auch schon mit delta
natürlich die durchbruchs infektion
kommen mit omikron erst recht aber das
ist ihre angst also wir sehen die
ungeimpften als schuldige dass wir
überhaupt noch gewonnen haben und die
anderen haben natürlich genauso viel
angst vor der impfung und das sehe ich
auch als ein problem das man die
menschen die das skeptisch sind die
vorbehalte haben die sorgen haben oder
die auch einfach sagen ich bin jung ich
bin gesund ich bin nicht die
risikogruppe dass man die jetzt alle in
einer ecke stellt als sein dass jetzt
alles notorische impfgegner also das ist
überhaupt nicht der fall sondern lassen
überwiegend menschen die zum beispiel
mir auch schreiben wenn es klassische
impfstoffe gebe traditionelle impfstoffe
würde ich mich sofort impfen lassen und
statt das irgendwie aufzunehmen
vielleicht den menschen auch
entgegenzukommen verband man sie in eine
angebliche extremisten ecke wo sie gar
nicht hingehören und ich sehe das auch
mit sorge was was das
demonstrationsrecht angeht also ich
finde dass es durchaus gründe gibt sich
dagegen zu wehren was jetzt teilweise
ascona politik verkauft würden aber man
kann es tatsächlich nicht machen weil
dann relativ schnell irgendeinen
grüppchen rechter irgendwo auftaucht und
die ganzen demo und wird dann nur unter
der rubrik gesehen aber da war irgendwie
ein raichs bürger und der hat ein plakat
hochgehalten natürlich muss man bei
anderen themen versuchen solche leute
draußen zu halten klar aber es sind ja
oft nicht gerade auch die professionelle
politiker die das organisieren sondern
eben initiativen bürger die einfach
irgendwie das gefühl haben wir müssen
unser unsere stimme erheben weil wir
haben sonst keine aspel bei ganz ganz
vielen menschen ich glaube man kann
sogar sagen bei millionen menschen dass
sie genau das nicht mit sich machen
lassen wollen sich in eine ecke drängen
lassen wollen bei weitem keine
radikalinskis sind und aber keine
möglichkeit mehr haben sich auszudrücken
denn in der öffentlichen diskussion auch
in der privaten diskussion auch am
arbeitsplatz auch im sportverein acht
auch am stammtisch überall ist so eine
art nun lieber nicht darüber reden und
das besorgt mich weil das ist
normalerweise etwas was irgendwann dann
mal bumm macht und sich bahn bricht und
ein neuer bundeskanzler musste es
eigentlich aufnehmen und darf nicht
sagen dass existiert alles gar nicht
existiert nicht kein problem muss ich
auch keins lösen das ist zu einfach olaf
scholz